One of the funnier, lighter moments in Game
of Thrones Season 6 is Tormund’s adorable
crush on Brienne of Tarth.
Brienne doesn’t reciprocate, sadly, but
in the books there are hints of another woman
Tormund may have a secret romance with.
You know how Daenerys is famous for having
a lot of titles – she’s Daenerys Targaryen,
“First of Her Name, Queen of Meereen, Queen
of the Andals and the Rhoynar and the First
Men, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms, Protector
of the Realm, Khaleesi of the Great Grass
Sea”, Stormborn, the Unburnt, Mother of
Dragons , myhsa and “Breaker of Chains”
. Well, in the books, Tormund, too, has many
names.
They call him “Tormund Giantsbane, Tall-talker,
Horn-blower, and Breaker of Ice”.
“Tormund Thunderfist, Husband to Bears,
the Mead-king of Ruddy Hall, Speaker to Gods
and Father of Hosts” . Tormund’s quite
a different character in the books compared
to the show – he’s more funny, always
joking, drinking, telling tall stories.
And one tale he tells explains one of his
titles – “Husband to Bears”.
The story goes that one cold winter’s night,
Tormund was drinking alone, when he decided
to go visit a woman he knew nearby.
He went out, got a bit lost, but eventually
found the woman, and, though she fought him,
got her out of her furs and had sex with her.
When Tormund woke up the next morning, he
found his body ripped and torn, half his penis
bitten off, and “a she-bear’s pelt”
lying beside him.
Turns out he had sex with a bear, and supposedly
a “bald bear” is later seen in the woods,
with “the queerest pair o’ cubs behind
her” . This story obviously isn’t literally
true – Tormund’s a notorious “bag of
wind and lies” , called “Tall-talker”
after all – but there are hints that the
story might be loosely based in truth, possibly
revealing a secret relationship between Tormund
and Lady Maege Mormont.
House Mormont is a northern family based on
Bear Island, up near the Wall.
They’re led by Jeor Mormont ‘til he joins
the Night’s Watch, then by Jorah Mormont
‘til he flees Westeros after selling slaves
– he ends up serving with Daenerys.
So now the leader of House Mormont is Lady
Maege, who’s called “the She-Bear” . So
the theory here is that Tormund’s story
of “a she-bear” is not really about an
actual bear – it’s about “the She-Bear”
of Bear Island, Maege Mormont.
And there are hints supporting this.
Tormund describes both the woman he knows
nearby and the she-bear as having a “temper”.
Maege is described as “stubborn”, “willful”,
and “short-tempered”.
Maege is also described as a “stout” and
“strong” “warrior” which fits with
Tormund’s descriptions of “a fine strong
woman”, and of the fighting she-bear.
It is a bit confusing whether Maege is more
the woman Tormund knows or the She-Bear in
this story, maybe it’s a bit of both.
But the point is that Tormund’s she-bear
story does seem to have connections with the
She-Bear of Bear Island, Lady Maege.
And there’s more, cause Lady Maege has five
daughters, though no one seems to know who
the father is, or if Maege has a husband . Maege’s
daughter Alysane, who herself has a couple
of kids, also apparently has no husband.
She says “Mormont women are skinchangers.
We turn into bears and find mates in the woods.
Everyone knows” . This, again, is probably
not literally true, but it supports the idea
that Mormont women are metaphorically she-bears,
out in the woods mating with men like Tormund.
This also could make logistical sense.
Bear Island is very close to the wildling
lands beyond the Wall.
Maege says that it’s because of the threat
of being “carried off” by ironmen or by
wildlings that Mormont women need to be warriors
. So it’d make sense for Tormund and Maege
to have met during a wildling raid on Bear
Island.
In Tormund’s story he claims to have carried
the “she-bear” back to his home, which,
in wildling culture, constitutes a marriage
– thus making Tormund “Husband” to “the
She-Bear”.
Of course none of this sounds terribly consensual
on Maege’s part, what with the talk of carrying
off, and the fighting she-bear.
But there’s reason to believe that this
relationship between Tormund and Maege, if
it exists, may be consensual and positive
and ongoing, partly because of the positive
way Alysane talks about the Mormont she-bears
mating in the woods, and partly because the
way Tormund talks about the woman who lives
nearby does sound like an ongoing relationship,
but also because an ongoing consensual relationship
could better explain Maege’s daughters.
Tormund says that the “she-bear” bears
him “cubs” – children – maybe these
are Maege daughters, those of the mysterious
unknown father.
Tormund also mentions “sons”, which might
mean that Maege is the mother of some of Tormund’s
four sons . It sounds almost as though Maege
chooses to keep her five daughters, but gives
her sons to be raised by Tormund beyond the
Wall – though it’s hard to imagine how
Maege could do all this secretly.
This is a lot of kids to come from a secret
relationship across the Bay of Ice, so maybe
only some of the kids are the children of
Tormund with Maege.
But even if it’s only some, that’s very
significant.
Maege and Tormund may not be the first wildling-non-wildling
relationship in the series – there’s Jon
and Ygritte, and Gilly and Sam – but Maege
Mormont is the Lady of Bear Island, a ruler
in the north – if her kids have free folk
blood in ’em, if lil’ Lyanna Mormont is
half wildling, that could really impact the
attitudes of people in the north, who of course
mostly hate wildlings.
Bridging this gap between the wildlings and
northmen is becoming more important with white
walkers on the way, and any connection between
Tormund and Maege could maybe help with this
alliance.
The hatred between northmen and wildlings
also adds a layer of tragedy to a relationship
between Tormund and Maege – they’re separated
by sides that have been enemies for centuries,
star-crossed like Romeo and Juliet with the
Montagues and Capulets.
And of course by Dance, Tormund and Maege
are split further apart – Tormund is at
Castle Black, while Maege is way down in the
Neck, possibly involved in a northern conspiracy.
The lovers are now so far apart.
“Would that I could find her again”, Tormund
says.
So look there’s no strong evidence for a
relationship between Tormund and Maege.
Tormund’s story may be just a story, and
Maege’s daughters may’ve been fathered
by some common man on Bear Island or something.
Fine.
But the hints and connections with “strong”
bad-tempered she-bears are there, and the
logistics and timing could work, so it is
at least fairly possible that “Husband to
Bears” Tormund and “the She-Bear” Maege
Mormont get together on one cold winter’s
night.
Thanks for watching this video.
If you’d like to help a team of academics
in their study of the Game of Thrones fandom,
go take their questionnaire at the link below.
Thank you to the Patrons for making this video
possible, including Melissa C Williams, Brett
Jensen, Ziggi Fuxman, Gavin Biggs, Tagard
McStone, Neil 'Roop' Ramroop, Lori Dallava,
and Full a' Stern.
Thanks also to Pauline on Twitter.
Cheers.